a royal rumble is growing between
buckingham palace and prince harry and
megan
all over the couple's revealing
interview coming up with oprah winfrey
prince harry and megan are no longer
holding back when it comes to the royal
family which they also call
the firm how do you feel about the
palace hearing you speak
your truth today i don't know how they
could expect
that after all of this time we would
still just be silent
if there is an active role that the firm
is playing
in perpetuating falsehoods about us
royal aides say after the wedding that
they had back in 2018 megan
bullied staff when she moved into the
royal household
they say she used quote emotional
cruelty and manipulation and drove
two aides out the door prince harry and
megan say they're victims of a
calculated smear campaign
buckingham palace says it is
investigating these claims
the couple has of course separated from
the royal family they now live in
southern california
you can watch the two-hour interview
oprah with megan and harry maybe you've
seen some promotion for this
a cbs primetime special right here on
channel 8 it is sunday at 8 o'clock
tune in